Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show.
I am David Pakman. If he was a giant oaf who got
stung by a thousand bees in the neck and then
swelled up and became this monstrosity before you.
Speaking of monstrosities, there's another
unplanned segway. I'm becoming very good at those.
Mike. Kevin McCarthy, not Mike McCarthy.
That's a that's a different person who
coaches football. Kevin McCarthy, Speaker of
the House of Representatives of these United
States. There's a lot of words that come to mind
when you think about Kevin McCarthy. Integrity
is not one that comes to mind. Intelligent
is not one that comes to mind necessarily.
But sycophantic is and a tool a useful
idiot for radicals in Congress certainly
comes to mind. He was on with Margaret
Brennan yesterday on Face the Nation
and gave a disastrous. Performance, just a
disastrous interview with Margaret Brennan.
And he was asked many, many questions, some of
which he he faked like he answered. He he has
this new thing that he does when when he's
answering a question with an answer that
isn't an answer to the actual question. He's just
like, man, let me answer your question the way I
say I'm going to answer the question. He's that's
his new tack is to become like a aggressive guy.
And he's asked two things. We're going to
play two clips here. One is about Jorge Santos
and about whether or not he should be expelled
from the body because you need two thirds of
the House of Representatives to
vote to expel him as a member.
They're not going to do that because they've
got a Democrat governor in New York. A number
of different reasons that are at play here.
But the other thing he's asked about is about
Marjorie Taylor GREENE being placed on the COVID
Origins Committee to investigate that. The same
woman who believes wearing a mask is like the
treatment of the Jews during the Holocaust.
The same woman who calls into question every
sudden death as a vaccine linked a woman who
believes 911 was a hoax. A woman who believes
Jews have lasers in space aimed at California
to fire a laser and start a forest fire. This
is a woman who has been elevated to the House
Oversight Committee and others of importance.
She went from having no committees at all
to some of the most elevated and sought after
committee assignments in the entire house. And
you would ask yourself, how is that? When she
spoke nothing but poison into the ear of Kevin
McCarthy and about Kevin McCarthy, and all
of a sudden they're they're thick as thieves,
they're pals. They're taking selfies together
on the floor of the house. It's a valid question
that should be asked. And it was asked by
Margaret Brennan, and this is what took place.
Speaker 2: These these are members who just
got elected by their constituents and we put
them into committees, and I'm proud to do it.
Speaker 3: Let me ask you about some specifics.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, you put her on a new
subcommittee to investigate the origins of COVID.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 3: She compared mask requirements
to the type of abuse Jews were subjected to
during the Holocaust. She called for force
you to be arrested and imprisoned, and she spread
conspiracy theories. How's anyone supposed to take
that work seriously and find that we're credible?
Speaker 2: Very well. You look at all of it. So
you have all the questions out there.
I think what the American. You think.
Speaker 3: These are legitimate.
Speaker 2: Questions. I think what
the American public wants to see is an
open dialog in the process. This is a
select committee where people can have all the
questions they want and you'll see the outcome.
Speaker 1: Those are nonsense answers from Kevin
McCarthy that we need. All the questions need to
be asked. No, they don't. Not all questions are on
the same level. Kevin McCarthy Not all questions
are valid of the work of a of a special select
committee in the House of Representatives. Open
dialog. We're just asking questions. This is this
is the work of conspiracy theory. This is how they
act. This is what they say. We're just asking
questions. What's wrong with asking questions?
And when you put someone like this as pernicious
and sinister and indeed stupid as Marjorie Taylor
GREENE on this committee, it diminishes
the work that they will do. But again,
it doesn't matter to Republicans, but they're not
in it for credible findings. They're in it for the
theater of it. They're in it for the show of it.
Now, I was going to play this other clip first,
but I chose to do it second. And that
is his absolute refusal to answer the
question about getting rid of Jorge Santos
or what they're going to do at all. Instead,
he starts talking about proxy voting and the
House being broken. And when she forces him or
tries attempts to make a force to him to answer
the question, he's not having it. He's doing that
thing that I talked about earlier. Watch this.
Speaker 3: But doesn't it further wear down
credibility when you put someone who is
under state, local, federal and international
investigation as a representative of
your party and swalwell's? I'm talking
about George Santos, representative from.
Speaker 2: New York. We should have that
discussion. So let's have that discussion. You
want to bring up Santos and let's talk about the
institution itself, because I agree wholeheartedly
that Congress is broken. And I think you I think
your listeners or viewers should understand what
proxy voting was because it never took place.
Speaker 3: But I'm asking you about Jorge Santos.
Speaker 2: I know you asked
me a question. Let me ask.
Speaker 3: If you could put it to a vote.
Speaker 2: You asked me a question. I'd appreciate
if you let me answer. So let's go through this
because it's not one simple answer. Congress
is broken based upon what has transpired in the
last Congress. The American public wasn't able
to come in to see us. People voted by proxy,
meaning you didn't have to show up for work.
Bills didn't go have to go through committee.
So what I'm trying to do is open the people's
house back for the people so their voices there
so people are held accountable. So now, as I
just had in the last week, for the first time
in seven years, every member got to vote.
Speaker 3: You got a third of your caucus
to vote to oust him. You could do so. You don't
think you could get your Republicans to do that?
Speaker 2: I wasn't finished answering the
question. So if every single new person brought
into Congress was elected by their constituents,
what their constituents have done has lent their
voice to the American public so those members can
all serve on committee. Now, what I'm trying to
do is change some of these committees as well,
like the Intel Committee is a different thing.
Speaker 3: So you're just not going
to answer the question? Well, no.
Speaker 2: I know you don't get a
question whether I answer it. You
ask the question I'm trying to get.
Speaker 3: I don't think you've said
the name Jorge Santos like once.
Speaker 2: But you know what.
Speaker 1: I'm talking.
Speaker 3: About.
Speaker 2: No, no, no. But, you know, you started
the question with Congress was broken, and I agree
with you. But I was answering the question of how
Congress is broken and how we're changing it. So
if I can finish the question that you asked me
how Congress has broken, I equated every single
member. They just got elected by their by their
constituents. They have a right to serve. So that
means that Santos can serve on a committee the
same way Swalwell, who had a relationship with a
Chinese spy. But they will not serve on Intel.
Speaker 3: They're wrong.
Speaker 2: Because I think.
Speaker 3: It's all room because, well.
Speaker 2: That's unfortunate. I wish
I could answer the question there.
Speaker 3: I would love to have you back.
Speaker 2: I would love to be able to
come back and have time to answer the question.
Speaker 1: Not smart. Listen, there are skilled
politicians who are very adept at doing the thing
that Kevin McCarthy wishes he could do, which is
you're asked a question and you answer an entirely
different question and then it just moves on.
He's not good at it. Instead, he gets
called out, blatantly overt, like, Well,
you're not going to answer the question then.
And he doesn't. He filibusters for four for just
about 2 minutes in that space. Refusing to answer
the easiest of questions. And you know what? It's
going to catch him because George Santos and all
the investigations that are taking place relative
to financial impropriety, to campaign finance
impropriety, it's going to come back. And he's
innocent until proven guilty thing isn't going
to play any more when George Santos eventually,
possibly gets convicted of these crimes and
they are crimes. Some of the things that he's
being accused of now, it's not just he lied about
his mom dying on 911, as despicable as that is,
it's not just lying about being a volleyball star
with replaced knees. There are serious issues that
Kevin McCarthy isn't qualified, isn't capable,
and has no desire to try to get to the bottom of.